[Music]
this not so little piece of equipment
could
change astronomy forever
and it could be about to find alien life
maybe in a matter of days
what is this powerful new tool
how could it detect life in galaxies far
away
and if it does find life
what would happen next
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the james webb telescope found
alien life
the james webb space telescope launched
into space on december 25th 2021
its mission
to study the history of our universe
from the afterglow of the big bang
to the formation of solar systems like
our own
this large infrared telescope is 100
times more powerful than the hubble
telescope it has 18 separate mirror
segments made of ultra lightweight
beryllium
these unfold and adjust to form a six
and a half meter primary mirror
now that the webb telescope has reached
its destination
one and a half million kilometers away
from the earth it should be able to see
into the past of our universe
it could be the key to discovering alien
life
unless they find us first
if you were looking for signs of life on
distant exoplanets you wouldn't look for
little green aliens
you'd look for biosignatures
in other words characteristics in a
planet's atmosphere that could be
evidence of life in the past or present
imagine an alien astronomer from a
distant galaxy pointing a telescope
toward earth
the biosignatures they'd make note of
are the presence of oxygen and methane
in our atmosphere
without life forms breathing these two
gases in and out
these elements would react with others
and disappear
so the james webb telescope will look
for the presence of oxygen and methane
too first you need to detect the
presence of an exoplanet around a
distant star
you could do this through the transit
method
as a planet passes in front of a star
you'd observe its light slightly
diminishing
after that planet passes in front of its
star many times
you'd have enough data to take
measurements of its atmosphere
you'd be able to see how much light goes
through its atmosphere and you could
determine what atmospheric elements
exist there based on the way the light
disperses
with a telescope as powerful as the web
you could gather enough data after a
planet has passed its star as few as 5
to 10 times
yeah so after only 20 hours of
investigating a planet
you could detect conditions for life
what
then what 100 for sure
well you probably wouldn't go public
with this information right away
you'd probably want to follow the
confidence of life detection scale
commonly referred to as cold
this is an approach that scientists at
nasa are looking to establish
it would set up a new framework for
discussing how close we are to finding
life beyond our planet
the scale would have seven levels
level one would be the detection of
biosignatures
as more data is collected you'd climb
the scale to level seven
at this point you'd likely find alien
life
and that's when the whole world freaks
out and powerful aliens beam down to
conquer our planet
right not exactly
if we discover life using the webb
telescope
it would be more than likely that we are
the powerful intelligent beings
the bombshell announcement of alien life
would be a lot less dramatic than the
movies suggest
it could take decades
be prepared for a slow progression of
countless mini announcements and
remember that the distances between
earth and exoplanets of interest
are vast
so if you decided to take an
interstellar trip to one of those like
the exoplanet trappist-1 e
it would take you decades
but scientists believe that this planet
may have atmospheric conditions similar
to ours
or at least similar to the earth two and
a half to four billion years ago
so
maybe we could find microscopic life
there
a discovery like this would elicit many
different reactions
for you it could be a dream come true
but for others it could be concerning
it could affect your entire
understanding of life in the universe
[Music]
surely there would be plenty of
ramifications to a discovery so huge
but would they be as big as discovering
aliens are already here
living inside the earth
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]